en este vídeo continuamos viendo las
funciones trigonométricas inversas antes
que nada les recuerdo brevemente cómo
funciona la cosa si vamos por la calle y
alguien nos dice oye tú cuánto es el
arco seno
el arco seno de x cuanto vale esto
pues eso para empezar es exactamente lo
mismo así nos preguntan cuánto vale la
función inversa el seno se pone este
menos uno no es que esté elevando el
seno a la potencia menos uno no estoy
dividiendo entre el seno sino este menos
uno hace referencia a la función inversa
del seno del valor x cuánto vale eso
pues entonces nosotros lo que hacemos es
nos preguntamos bueno lo único que está
diciendo esta persona es que tengo un
ángulo un ángulo que no sé cuánto vale y
el seno de ese ángulo es igual a equis
así que lo único que tengo que encontrar
es este ángulo siguiendo la misma lógica
si me preguntan cuánto es la arco
tangente
arco tangente de un valor x esto cuánto
vale de nuevo esto es exactamente lo
mismo que la tangente inversa de un
valor equis y entonces lo único que
tengo que hacer es decir bueno pues si
lo que quiero averiguar es el arco
tangente de x lo que tengo que hacer es
encontrar un ángulo theta tal que la
tangente de teta sea igual a
hagamos un ejemplo para aclarar las
cosas vamos a decir que nos preguntan
bueno oye cuánto vale la arco tangente
al arco tangente de menos 1 cuánto es
esto que es exactamente lo mismo a que
me pregunten cuánto vale la tangente a
la menos 1 la tangente inversa de menos
1 estas dos cosas son dos variantes de
exactamente la misma pregunta y bien
antes de atacar esto quiero que
recordemos brevemente cómo funciona la
tangente de un ángulo supongamos que
tengo
la tangente de un ángulo teta pues yo sé
de la lista de reproducción de
trigonometría o de sus clases que esto
es lo mismo tangente de teta que tomar
el seno de teta
y dividirlo entre el coseno de eta
entonces como se ve esto en el círculo
unitario me voy a poner aquí
cgs
por ello es también que x
y mi círculo unitario
se vería algo así entonces si yo tengo
un ángulo theta digamos así
estoy aquí vale teta entonces la
coordenada de este punto sería x en la
coordenada la intersección y yo sé que
el seno de teta es igual a la coordenada
ye
coordenada
y el coseno beteta es igual a la
coordenada x
coordenada x que esto de aquí
esto de aquí sería el seno de zeta
y esto de acá sería el coseno de tetra
el coche no detecta de modo que esto si
me fijo en la recta roja es el cambio
y esto es el cambio en x el avance y el
alza entonces si me fijo en la tangente
que sería el seno etc entre el seno de
tetas sería lo mismo que el alza entre
el avance pero que es eso pues eso es
precisamente la pendiente de esta recta
la pendiente y eso va a ser igual a la
tangente de theta tengamos esto en
cuenta para resolver la pregunta que nos
plantearon entonces cuánto vale de nuevo
la arco tangente
de menos 1 pues veamos déjenme hago otro
dibujo
suponer viaje
mi otro eje
en nuestro círculo unitario
y ahora necesito considerar una recta
con pendiente menos 1 esa recta es
precisamente la recta igual a menos x y
se ve algo así ahora bien cuánto vale
este ángulo que es lo que quiero
encontrar pues para que esta recta tenga
pendiente menos 1 esta distancia aquí
esta instancia tiene que ser igual a
esta distancia me alza tiene que ser
igual a menos mi avance en este caso el
alza es negativa porque estoy yendo
hacia los negativos pero bueno como este
ángulo de aquí es recto y estos dos
lados son iguales en magnitud
estos dos ángulos también tienen que ser
iguales y como todos los ángulos de un
triángulo suman 180 grados cada uno de
ellos debe valer 45 grados déjenme
incluso podría copiar el triángulo acá
fuera como dos lados son iguales y tengo
un ángulo recto entonces este ángulo
vale 45 grados de hecho nosotros ya
sabemos cuánto vale cada uno de los
lados que a uno de los lados valdría
raíz de 2
sobre dos creo que esto lo vimos en el
vídeo anterior pero si no les queda de
ejercicio sencillo entonces este ángulo
sería de 45 grados pero como estoy yendo
a favor de las manecillas del reloj y me
estoy yendo hacia abajo del eje x puedes
llamar este ángulo de menos 45 grados
menos 45 grados de modo que tengo que la
tangente
la tangente de menos 45 grados sería la
coordenada del punto de intersección
entre la coordenada x que es menos raíz
de 2 entre 2 / raíz de 2 entre 2 que es
menos 1 o dicho de otro modo el arco
tangente de menos 1 es igual a 45 grados
o si lo quieren poner en radiales
incluso lo único que tienen que hacer es
tengo 45 grados y tengo irradian es
irradian es por cada 180 grados 180
grados grados cancela grados por así
decirlo 45 entre 180 a perdón aquí es
menos con el 35 que también debería ser
menos 45 menos 45 grados menos 45 grados
menos 45 grados entre 180 grados es a un
cuarto de modo que todo esto me da
- y cuartos
los cuartos de radiantes
bueno pero quizás también nos pasa lo
mismo que nos había pasado antes qué
sucede si por ejemplo siguió dando la
vuelta okay salgo de aquí llegó este
ángulo y continúa le doy otra vuelta
entonces debería dar la misma tangente
no incluso este punto debería darme la
misma tangente pues de hecho es cierto
pero así como lo hicimos con el cose lo
inverso y con el seno inverso tenemos
que restringir nuestro rango tengo que
restringir el rango de valores que puede
tomar de otro modo terminó con una
situación así la arco tangente
el arco tangente de menos 1 acabo de ver
que es menos pi cuartos de radiant es
menos pi cuartos ok pero si le sumo
cualquier número de vueltas alrededor
del círculo unitario se le sumó un 2 pi
cualquier número de veces esto también
me daría un valor aceptable para el arco
tangente a menos de que restrinja mi
rango eso es lo que tenemos que hacer
porque de otro modo tendríamos que el
mismo valor de x larco tangente de
digamos menos 1 se va o vale distintas
cosas no podemos tener una función multi
valuaba esto podríamos decir que es
menos pi cuartos de radiales pero que es
lo mismo que 2 p - pi cuartos y eso es
lo mismo que 4 p - pi cuartos
esto no se puede ok entonces tenemos que
restringir nuestro rango lo que voy a
hacer es decir el arco tangente solo
puede tomar valores dentro de esta parte
de la circunferencia y ni siquiera puedo
incluir los extremos este punto de
medios y este punto en menos y medios
porque hay la tangente involucra una
división por cero la pendiente de una
recta vertical no está definida de modo
que me escribo todo eso que hemos
discutido si tengo que la tangente de
teta es igual a equis entonces x puede
valer pues x es la pendiente de alguna
recta así que x puede valer
esencialmente lo que sea es un número
que puede estar entre menos infinito
e infinito positivo puede valer
esencialmente lo que sea pero si lo que
quiero es considerar los zetas tales que
el arco tangente de x es igual a theta
entonces me voy a restringir a que menos
y medios menos y medios es menor
estricto que teta que es menor que mi
medios eso esencialmente cancela estas
posibilidades y me dice que para cada x
sólo hay un único ángulo en este rango
en donde la tangente el arco tangente
está bien definida bueno ya solo
chequemos nuestro trabajo con la
calculadora así que quiero la tangente
inversa de menos 1
y me da este valor de aquí 78 que
debería ser lo mismo que menos pi
cuartos así que cuánto vale menos pi
cuartos
y me da exactamente lo mismo así que
estamos en lo correcto la arco tangente
de menos 1 es menos pi cuartos de
radiales o lo que es lo mismo menos 45
grados